[Music]
michelle is in evansville indiana hi
michelle welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave i'm glad i got through to you
today long time listener um i have a
little complex situation
um
my parents filed bankruptcy back uh my
latter latter teen years so mid 80s
there were um some property that was
given to us or by that dollar
transaction from an ant totaling about
probably 40 or so acres
with a separate section cut out to build
a home on after they filed bankruptcy
that was about a house built in five
acres
um long story short my sister my parents
couldn't take out a loan so she was of
18 years old so they took the loan out
to my sister's name and deeded the
ground and the home to separate deeds in
my sister mai's name
she's since married and she um her and
her husband now are on the deed along
with myself
my question is this we do not get along
um
my father has passed
my mother had a lifetime estate to this
property for as long as she lived she
could live here
however my sister was her caregiver and
there has been some discord that my
sister was basically maltreating my
mother and so my mother has relinquished
her rights to this property
so
i have never been interested in this
property
it is not my homestead my sister lives
adjoining property that my father and
mother gave her and her husband for a
wedding present
so when i have mentioned
i live in evansville indiana so i am in
different states where's the house
where's the property
illinois southern southern very tip so
crazy is in a pile in illinois and
you're not in the pile of crazy
i am not in the pile of crazy never
wanted pile of crazy have asked to be
purchased have bought out things like
that until this recent transaction when
my mom decided i want out of this i'm
moving up north with my other family
nieces and nephews
and i said to my sister then once she
had mom sign off the deed i went out i
want you guys to buy me out and she said
just sell it
well it's hard to sell a home and for
five acres half of it to
someone
without her authority
and her agreeing i guess
you have two choices okay
you don't have anything in this
i do not
you can indeed it to her and walk away
from crazy
okay
that's probably what i would do
okay
life's too short
it is this is a screwed up pal mess
it is these people these people have
done everything they can to duck reality
for decades and twist and turn and the
whole thing's a pretzel
and um
now the other option is technically
legally you are partners and you could
file a lawsuit in chancery court
for the disillusionment of the
partnership which would force the sale
of the real estate
okay
and you would get your half
okay
what would you guess your half is worth
uh
well in that area right now it's going
for roughly six thousand dollars an acre
plus their standing timber that my dad
what do you think the problem is
between that the house and the other
anchorage probably around 150 to 200.
your half
my house 75 to 100.
no probably closer to two 150 to two
your half is worth 150 to two okay
correct between because there's a house
and five acres and there's additional
like 20 to 40 acres with timber so just
how much trouble you want to go to to
get that because it's probably gonna
cost you 30 grand in legal fees
okay
and you will win
and you will lose
right
right no there is no winning when it
comes to family so the only thing that
the only thing the only ones that win
these things are the lawyers
but you will you will
i would guess if you have a decent
attorney that you will
uh the the judge will hear you and say
this thing has to be liquidated because
or he'll look at your sister and say buy
her out
one or two and your sister will go okay
i'll do that or
no or whatever but you cannot sell a
one-half undivided interest it has no
value
because nobody else wants to be partners
with these crazy people either
no i don't
no i don't i would give you ten thousand
dollars to not make me a partner
exactly well i i would love to turn
around and walk away i was married for
22 years and actually walked away from
about 350 000 in assets and gave that to
the ex-husband
you know the other thing that could
happen i guess is you could file the
lawsuit or have the attorney let her
know put her on notice that you're
filing the suit you're not suing her
you're asking for the judge to make a
declaration
she hasn't done anything wrong you're
just asking for the judge to just to
declare that this partnership needs to
be dissolved because i'm positive there
are no partnership documents
no no actually men of course i was
probably 15 or 16 when this all took
place 40 or plus years ago
as a minor i knew nothing so and they
did this with your sister's permission
or they stole her identity
no actually the sister was of age and
she wanted them to be able to build a
home so she went out and took this loan
out and had me as a co-signer on it as a
15 year old well that's not legal either
no it's not there's a lot of 15 year old
co-signer you can't even buy cigarettes
no i
[Laughter]
not really no beer or cigarettes but
i'll give you a house yeah john i mean
you see anything from the family
standpoint i don't think there's
anything heals this mess no nothing
can you afford to walk away
i can i can
i know the sad thing is i know it's not
my parents wishes but yes i can and i am
a walk away person so
your parents
um
they created a mess
and it's you're not your obligation to
fix the mess to to
create a picture that's gonna satisfy
something that they you see what i'm
saying
going to be putting together puzzle
pieces on a puzzle and the picture keeps
shifting on you if you have the energy i
might you know
spiritually it's okay to just say i'm
going to rise above this toss on the
keys okay
there's something freeing about just
doing that and noble about doing that
um from a just a legal strategy
standpoint uh you could just file the
thing
without going to a huge amount of
expense if you want to drop
i don't know five thousand dollar
retainer with a good lawyer and see if
that doesn't bring her to the table
okay because when she discovers what
this is actually going to do it's going
to force the sale of the real estate
that is next door to her
she may come up and go okay if you'll
make me a deal i'll buy you out and i
would sell it to her for 50 of what it's
worth
yeah but that way you get that way you
get 75 grand out of it or something
instead of nothing
yeah
sorry if you want if you want to put a
bluff on the table that's the way to put
but i i honestly would not play it all
the way through
and force the auction
and the drama of the auctioneer if you
win everybody loses yeah i just there's
no winning this deal
i wouldn't go through all that but i
might make her think i'm going to i'm in
for that see if she could come to the
table let's see if we can give her a
little redneck wake-up call